[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships George camel Ramsey
Personality YouTube sensation and best
and new
minted bestselling author is my co-host
today his brand new book I'm proclaiming
it a bestseller it isn't technically yet
but it will be Breaking Free from broke
the Ultimate Guide to more money and
less stress and by attacking all of the
uh evil villains out there in the money
space George very carefully and um with
great craftsmanship unpacks all of the
uh traps that you have to avoid and the
people that are out there to get you and
in the process gives you hope that's the
goal and the feedback has been amazing
on that it did exactly that people are
saying you have dismantled not only the
myths but all of the objections that
I've had toward a debt-free lifestyle
and the things that you've heard over 30
years Dave and I've heard them on the
show as we take calls and so what I
tried to do with the book was get in
their heads before they could even say
it and say I know what you're thinking
right now I pay off my card every month
I've never paid a diamond interest we've
heard all of these things over 30 years
and what I wanted to do was not just
just you have some kind of emotional
opinion but actually give you data and
research and analogies and empathy and
humor to help you understand why your
plan ain't working for you so far and a
different plan that could actually
work well and you clearly Define I mean
and we talk about it on the show here a
lot what normal is normal sucks and if
you're going to be normal you're messed
up and Romans 12:2 says be not conformed
to this world don't be normal but
instead be be
transformed how by the renewing of your
mind and you do that by putting
information like this book in and the
result is Hope yeah and that it starts
with that paradigm shift because why
would you even attempt any of this
Ramsay plan if you don't believe it's
possible and so when you start to think
differently the renewing of your mind
you begin to act differently and when
you act differently and we see this on
the debt free stage you believe that a
different life is possible it's amazing
the relationship between those three I'm
amazed people can run through a wall
when they have hope yeah and uh that you
know they can't cut they can't cut paper
they can't get out find their way out of
a wet paper bag when they have believed
that the little man can't get ahead they
believe they're trapped they believe
there's no chance of winning because
there's plenty of people out there to
tell you that oh it's so easy you look
at the headlines and it's easy to lose
hope it's the it's the it's the natural
state of mediocrity and of loser talk
and busting through the loser talk and
you know getting I'm not going to live
like this I'm not going to live like
this and and then you see a path you see
I think I could go from here to over
there I actually see what George is
saying I think it's doable and and
that's called hope when you open up that
path and it's a believable path away
from mediocrity away from friends and
relatives that tell you it can't be done
well and I was that guy I was cynical
back in 2013 as the guy who followed all
the fell for all the traps and followed
the path told me $40,000 in Consumer
Debt I was cynical toward adulthood and
so I actually end the book with a
chapter called ignorance was Bliss cuz I
believe you know too much to still stay
broke after reading this book and so I
tell people it's easy to be cynical you
can wake up every day and decide to be
cynical what's harder is deciding to be
hopeful and choosing hope and then
creating the habits that get you out of
that Meer that you've created and so I
tell people it's not all their fault but
it's their responsibility no one's going
to come saving you and so you got to
drop the victim mentality for this
Victor mentality and it's not easy it's
not all woo woo it takes real action
yeah and part of the action is clearly
identifying that there are some people
out there operating in the world that do
not have your best interest at heart
hello their job is not to help you their
job is to take stuff from you and um
legalized fraud you know we're going to
you know
legalized horrible Financial products
and you know everything from the stupid
time share which is definitely legalized
fraud uh to to the credit card point
that nobody ever redeems to the credit
score that is the gateway drug into all
of the debt yeah which is the you know
that's worshiping the golden calf there
you know the great FICO is now your
provider oh great FICO we bring you
offerings of stupidity and interest
what's amazing Dave is that you know
debt has not been around that long in
its current form our obsession with debt
especially American culture and so I
actually walk through the history of the
credit score and the history of the
credit card because it gives us some
perspective to go wait this thing was
like invented by the
90s that's crazy this wasn't around in a
grandparents day they thought thatb was
shameful the old American Express thing
don't leave home without it turns out
Daniel Boone did you know I mean who
knew it's it's a fairly new thing and
you're you're right and unpacking all of
that helps you to break free from broke
the Ultimate Guide to more money and
less stress and uh not because money
keep you from having stress but because
having a plan and a belief system that
leads you towards winning that will
lower your anxiety level uh immediately
even if your situation hasn't changed a
a clear path that you know works that
you can follow and I'm now on that path
I'm going to put my right foot in front
of my left foot in front of my right
foot in front of my left foot and I'm
going to take a couple steps in this
Direction all of the sudden your anxiety
goes down even though your situation
hasn't changed yet absolutely and you've
talked about thisday for years that
money is a tool but for so many money is
an obstacle it's not a tool that they
can use to build wealth and give
generously instead it's a stress point
not a bless point so that's the point of
this book right here is to help you see
money in a different way help you create
the actions necessary and give you the
ick to go I need a shower after
understanding how this debt system
actually works and I now believe it's
possible to live without it what are two
or three of the ugliest things you found
in the things that these companies are
doing to people oh my goodness well I
interviewed an ex Capital One manager
who spilled the tea and said straight up
Capital One 10,000 experiments a year on
consumers to keep them trapped there is
a reason why they move from cash back to
points and rewards to try to confuse
consumers and they can devalue your
points at any time if you don't play
their game perfectly so that was one
piece and the other was a federal
reserve study that showed exactly where
credit card rewards comes from $15
billion is moved a wealth transfer from
the poor uneducated at to the wealthy
educated through credit card rewards so
for years people said well Dave My
Rewards come from transaction fees
Capital One is earning report says
otherwise 75% of capital 1's credit card
Revenue came from interest and fees
charged to people who are broke that's
how you got that free flight that
disgusted me Dave wow so you're
participating in wealth inequality whoa
look at that that that one was for the
social folks out there who were going
well you know if you're going to get on
your moral high horse there's an
argument that's hard to argue against
yeah and one lady even messaged me she
said hey I had done the Ramsey plan but
we kept the credit cards after reading
that chapter you convinced me to finally
cut him up I needed a shower after
reading that chapter and I'm we decided
we're done with this game yeah it's not
worth being a part of that system well
the these Goobs are not U agnostic
they're not without belief systems they
have a belief system and their belief
system says take all your money MH well
there's a reason Capital One sponsors
the Taylor Swift tour and we can't
afford tickets to the the Taylor Swift
tour they are winning you can't beat the
house The House Always Wins so stop
playing the Deb game be free there we go
the new book Breaking Free from broke
comes out it came out this week you can
pick it up anywhere that important books
are sold like ramsy solutions.com your
bookstore Amazon all those kinds of
things this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com and
save up to 35% off everything sitewide
that's blinds.com to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality
bestselling author is my co-host today
her new quick read money's not a math
problem hit the seller list last week so
uh big deal that's a that's your first
one on the list right yeah I didn't even
know that that was possible with a quick
read so here we are yeah sometimes we'll
sneak on there you never know good job
that's a lot of fun it's a great book
too great read David is in San
Bernardino California hi David welcome
to the Ramsey Show hey Dave thanks for
having my call sure what's up hey so
I've been watching your show since I was
like 17 it's done me pretty good thank
god um I'm about 25 years old now I
graduated in 20 21 um I've paid off all
my student loans and I just got myself
back into debt by buying an investment
property um I have about $75,000 in
savings and 15,000 in stocks um and I
was wondering if I should take that 90k
and drop it into this first investment
property to pay off as much as I can of
it or if I should drop it on a down
payment for a second investment property
well if you've been listening to me as
much as you say you have you know the
answer to that
question that's accurate um I
guess I guess my my question was if I if
I'm in an area where I know I'll have
tenants um I know you always say you're
not you can't depend on them always
paying your rent or your mortgage for
you but do I take that risk if I'm so
I'm living with my parents right now I
don't have my own
mortgage is it a risk that you would
think is worth taking or is it just an
automatic no
I don't borrow money because I don't
think it's a risk worth taking and I
have not for 30 years told anyone ever
once to go borrow money for an
investment property because I don't
think it's a risk worth taking and
that's probably not going to change
today David what do you owe on the first
mortgage the one that you have the
rental so I just bought it two weeks ago
um it's a $400,000 property and I
dropped 20% so I've got I think 325 left
on that yeah I would definitely take
this money I'd probably cash out the
stocks I'd take the 75,000 I'd set aside
three to six months of your personal
expenses keep that aside and then i'
throw the rest at this
Mortgage and pay it off as quickly as
possible okay that that sounds good I
mean the 990,000 I'm talking about is
aside from any uh emergency fund I've
got that set aside already yeah D David
there's three rules in
business it takes twice as long as you
think it's going to it costs twice as
much as it think think it's going to and
you're not the
exception and so you're all brigh eyed
and bushy tailed and you act like that
you can automatically get a renter and
you're in an unusual situation so that
there's no risk and you're wrong there
is risk it takes twice as long as you
think it's going to it's going to cost
twice as much as you think it's going to
the renters are going to pay half as
much as you think they're going to pay
and half the time when you think they're
going to pay and you're G to you're
going to discover the that real estate
is anything but a passive investment
it's a very active investment you have
to be very actively involved or you're
GNA get your butt chewed up and uh the
less debt you have the higher the
likelihood that you're going to
survive investing in real estate much
less Thrive I hope he can afford that
mortgage payment if he doesn't have a
renter yeah otherwise he's going to be
up a creek without a paddle yeah yep
that's the thing so guys uh I don't want
to uh pick on Dave right straight David
straight out of the shoot here but um
let me just go ahead and I I'll remind
some of you that are fairly new to this
place um if you come on here and you say
I've been listening to you for 10 years
um and you know what I'm going to say
don't be shocked that I say what you
think I was going to say because it's
kind of been the same you're very
consistent Dave yeah I mean my my pastor
said Dave you're a one- trick pony you
only have one story and I said we'll
show to you one sermon that's hilarious
so true been preaching the same
thing oh there you go open phones atle
8825 5225 Natalie's in Los Angeles hi
Natalie how are
you hi thank you for taking my call
today sure what's up um my question is
my husband and I have been savings for
uh a house for almost 6 years our plan
we thought would be 3 to five years but
then Co happened and everything and the
inflation and um we still are in a
position where we can afford a house and
so my question is um we have money saved
and I'm not sure what we should do with
it because it's just sitting in the bank
how much do you have
saved we have about 990,000 and my goal
is by the end of the summer we'll have
100 that's awesome so can you just drop
it in a high yield savings account like
one of those online
ones um I mean the rates are pretty
decent right
now so how like how long would you
suggest I guess you just the high old
savings accounts don't have a time on
them uhuh you can just drop it in there
and kind of set it just forget about it
and when you're ready to use that money
you can pull it out there's no
stipulation on pulling the money
out oh okay mhm um
the uh uh I'm a little curious what's
your household income
so we have like a a very unique
situation we live in LA county um my
husband is a school teacher we live just
on his income but we don't pay any
housing expenses we manage a property so
I'm a property manager what's his
household what's your household income
um yeah so it's 57 a month after taxes
and health insurance okay so he's making
$80,000 a year and You' saved about
$220,000 a year for five years right
okay yeah how much house are you trying
to
get when the time comes at this point
it's like I'm not very picky like
whatever we can get well that's you got
to be a little bit more specific than
that we're talking about prices and
money so what do you think you're going
to
spend um I'm not quite sure we've kind
of said maybe we'll leave the state um
but we just haven't made that decision
yet you live in one of the most
expensive real estate counties in the
world
yeah and you make you know 75 $80,000 a
year um and so that that's what you've
got to consider um I mean La San Jose
San Francisco right um New York City
London Tokyo um these are super
expensive markets San Diego not far
behind right and so um you know not
telling you to move but um you know you
you may reach a point that what you get
paid you can't afford to live there Ian
you can't for here's an example okay you
can't make $50,000 a year and live in
Manhattan and own your home on your real
estate okay it's not mathematically
possible so there are some things that
you say I can't afford to live there and
have the house and have a house and have
the dream that I want to do and you're
you're probably pretty close on this one
listen my sister-in-law was a teacher
living in Los Angeles and they decided
that they moved to First first they
moved to North Carolina and then they
moved to North Florida and because
that's how they were going to afford the
house but I do think that if you take
some time and you guys do some research
look at different areas look at
different cities and states and really
create a clear picture for what you want
because I think that you could um easily
I I don't feel like there's a clear
Target so you're not really aiming at
anything clear it's just home ownership
but if you make a clearer Target I think
that you'll be more excited about saving
that money and you'll be more
intentional about actually getting to
the goal well that's exactly true that's
very true and you can start to make a
decision about career path and you know
where do we want what part of I maybe I
don't know if a teacher that works in LA
county has to technically live in LA
county that's true uh how you know how
much of a commute can we stand in other
words uh because La is not unlike most
other cities that the further you get
out of town uh in most directions uh the
cheaper the real estate uh It's Not
Unusual it's basic ring theory of urban
growth and so you know drop a pebble in
the center and as you go every ring you
go out other than you hit a lake or you
hit a mountain where the prices go up um
other than you hit uh a particular
neighborhood that is uh known for its
Prestige but other than those things as
you go out the Rings generally speaking
uh for most of you listening the further
out in the country you get the cheaper
the property I mean it's a pretty simple
concept and I think most most of us
walking around know that so you got to
deide that and then the other thing you
decide is do we want to live our our can
we live make the life we want to make
with the money we make in LA county and
if we can't then you'll be one of those
California refugees who uh ends up in
another state this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
default Ed private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refund financing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones atle
88255 225 Angie's in Salt Lake City Utah
hi Angie welcome to the Ramsey Show hi
Ramsey thank you so much for answering
my call um I'm 33 years old I just
graduated from grad school last month um
I decided to embark on this journey of
school January 2022 I moved away from
home Florida to Salt Lake City to pursue
the sport of I spe skating while I
finished my grad school program I had
the opportunity to just go to school and
train while out there I was not working
early throughout the year my father
passed away and it shipped my entire
world I saw some I I he left some
inheritance which helped me live through
and continue my journey out fa and train
my lease is now up and I didn't meet the
goals or finish the project I had in
mind um now I'm stuck whether I should
continue out here or move back to my
parents home and recalibrate did you get
the degree application huh did you get
the
degree I did I got
thee in uh my Master's in Business
Administration so why don't you go get a
job I am I'm in the process of doing
that right now now it's taking some time
why
and people are hiring
everywhere say that again people are
hiring everywhere you've got an MBA for
God's sakes I know I'm in the process of
that um why is it a process you should
get a
job like now I am interviewing exactly
good I'm interviewing right now where
are you
interviewing uh Gman right now Gman
Sachs no I'm talking about what
cities I Salt Lake City and Florida
Miami Florida okay good and what are
that what do those positions
pay right now they in Salt Lake City the
the cost is a lot lower so they're not
going more than 90 and I so you're
three-year-old full-grown woman that's
going to make $90,000 a year why would
you even consider living with your
mommy I know they just they came they
were like listen you have uh 200 uh, in
student de like if you just want to come
and recalibrate but I just don't I think
you've recalibrated
enough yeah
yeah yes my other option is whether to
continue in Utah or move back to Florida
due to the job market you go wherever
the job goes whoever's going to pay you
the most money go get you some money and
a life girl it's time yes it's time yes
you can't you can't can't Bob and weave
and duck anymore you get to face the
whole thing now you can do
it I could do it you can you can do it I
hear someone that's more capable than
she thinks she
is thank you it hasn't uh been easy this
past years um that I'm grateful for the
opportunity just thought that you know
if I do stay out in Salt Lake City um
and having the opportunity to instead of
paying
rent come back no it's not an
opportunity hey what's you're hiding
what's messing with your confidence
right now yeah
really my confidence is the fact that
you know I haven't defined the the
income yet uh I'm still in that process
but I know I'll get through and but I I
wouldn't even put living with Mommy on
the table Hun not even a option I want
you to go I want you to go out there and
lift some things and and grow your back
muscles so you got a strong
back okay you can do this you can do
this but you've had you've had different
things come at you and I I don't think
Jade and I know the whole story I think
there's a whole bunch of stuff back
there and then then the thing with your
dad and then you've been over there in
Salt Lake City and then you graduated
and you went oh crap I've really got to
go do this
now yeah yeah that's what happened yeah
and you do you do really got to go do
this now and here's the thing you really
can go do this getting an MBA is is not
an easy task you just accomplished a big
goal make a make a little Mark on your
little self-report card that says I just
did a big
thing thank you thank you I forget most
of the time due to the fact that I do I
hate loans I hate debt so it's just like
having that Deb under my name is just
like when am I going to finally pay it
off if I keep you're going to pay it off
when you get a big old job you work like
a crazy girl and you get the stuff paid
off and let's let's let's reframe how
we're viewing this debt like if you look
at if you look at a pile of debt and all
you feel is is fearfulness and oh my
gosh I did this and D you've got to
really refuel that and go and and
reframe that in your mind and say this
has got to be the fuel for the fire like
I've got $200,000 of debt I can't let it
paralyze me I've got to like lean into
it and go forward because if you keep
having that kind of off balance and I'm
scared of it feeling you're going to
just make minimum payments and find ways
to put it off and put it off before you
know it you look up and it's a bigger
pile so really let this feeling you
getting those notices this debt is due
let that fuel it do you understand what
I'm saying that's fueling your job
search that's fueling you moving to
whever the best job is that's fueling
you pouring as many payments and as much
money into this as possible to get it
paid off
quickly does that make sense that makes
sense 100% yes I don't want you running
home I if I'm if you're my daughter uh
my daughter's not a lot younger than you
I would tell you it's it it's the best
thing you can do is strengthen your
Wings by
flying and you're capable of flying
you're capable of soaring uh you've
proven that by getting your NBA take
some confidence from that now go get a
position get settled then go get a
better position get settled then go get
a better position get settled and when
you call me back you're making $150
$200,000 a year M and you paid all this
off and you know you're you're 38 years
old and you've slayed this dragon and
you can do it you can do it do not try
to hide anymore it's not serving you
well go get them Ronald is in Naples
Florida hey Ronald what's up hey how's
it going H thanks for having me on the
show sure how can I help yeah I just had
some just some advice questions I I feel
like I'm on the right track but I just
wanted to hear from somebody of stature
you know other than my dad who's he's an
investor he's got the mindset he's a
business owner but you know how hard it
is for a uh for a a son to hear
something from their father and take it
100% to heart um especially about money
and business decisions but um well I
recently just had um my son my very
first son um he just turned one a couple
of months ago and I'm just trying to
build
a basically a package for him you know
for when he turns my age he's got that
cushion or that pillow behind him I
don't want to necessarily turn him into
like you know waiting around for Dad to
die so I get my money um because that's
the way I was raised I had a cushion but
I still you know I work a full-time job
I work 50 60 70 80 hours a week
sometimes to accomplish my goals but I
just want to I want to see if I'm on the
right direction I think you need to
teach your son just like your dad did
you you teach him teach him to work
definitely he he instilled a lot of good
core values in me and I I've had the
same conversations with my dad I spoke
to him two days ago and he said you know
I'm I'm proud of what you're doing and
you're going in the right direction I
just want to make sure I'm not missing
any steps for my son a big old pile of
money is not what a grown young man
needs they need work ethic Integrity uh
honor abut dignity you instill those
things in them then they won't need
money they won't need money and if you
leave them money then they'll take that
money and do wonderful things with it if
they have those character qualities
that's where Legacy comes from
absolutely yeah um so much of that's GNA
be them watching you do those things
yeah it's it's hard to it's hard to show
them things like that though because a
five-year-old 8-year-old kid's not going
to understand looking at a computer yeah
they do they pick they they catch
everything kids catch kids catch and
absorb everything you would be shocked
and amazed more is caught than taught
yeah oh is it is my first My First Son
my friends got kids but this is my first
one so hey I'm going to send you Rachel
Rachel and I did a book together called
smart money smart kids how to teach kids
how to handle money and how to work and
how to give and how to save and how to
spend and um it was a number one
bestseller I'll send you a copy as my
gift and Ronald you're a great dad
you're going to do good
congratulations this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America the Ramsey Show question of the
day is brought to you by neighborly your
hub for Home Services in case you're a
new listener what does that mean exactly
well neighborly is a family of locally
operated home service providers who are
dedicated to giving homeowners excellent
service so start your search today at
neighborly decom Ramsey all right
today's question comes from Robert in
Minnesota he says last year against the
wishes of her mother and I my
18-year-old daughter signed a lease with
an apartment complex she committed to
one year but she never moved into the
apartment fast forward a year later and
now she's getting calls from a
collection agency to pay back around
9,000 for unpaid rent she's currently
going to college has no assets and no
income my wife and I are not willing to
help her pay for this but I'm trying to
help her navigate her options any advice
oh my goodness I'm wondering why she
never moved into it number one uh here's
the thing she owes the money like she
signed a lease she owes the money the
best you could try to do is maybe try to
settle it for less but she's going to
have to pay this money back she signed
and said that she would commit to pay a
certain amount of rent they don't know
or care whether or not she moved in or
not but because she occupied on paper
that space that's $99,000 of rent that
that owner lost out on so she owes it
and if you're her mom and dad I feel
like Dave you can ring it on this this
is what where my brain goes she's got
some options number
one man I don't know Dave I don't know
if I would pay it for her I no I would
not oh no but I mean like even like to
help her because it's only going to get
no it's only going to get more she's 18
she gets a
job get a job and pay it $9,000 I mean
come on you can do it it's a lot of
money it's not a lot of money I mean
just go I'm just go Uber your little
18-year-old butt off
seriously door Dash yourself until you
came walk come on really 9,000 bucks go
go clean it up baby doll now help her
navigate it
[Music]
uh that depends on how obstinate and
rebellious this girl is she obviously
was obstinate and rebellious when she
went against
your wishes is that what you called it
yeah your wishes said wishes you and
your you and your wife said don't do
this this is stupid so she lined up and
signed up for stupid and now she's got
got $9,000 of stupid and now if she's
like Dad I really screwed up and she's
repentant right would you help me with
this yes I'll help you here's what
you're going to do you're going to work
you're going to uh you're going to scoop
dog poop you're going to walk dogs
you're going to clip dogs hair you're
going to babysit kids you're going to do
door Dash You're going to work all the
time you're not going to have a social
life because you signed up for stupid
and you get to cover it and you can
clean this up in oh let's just say
$1,000 a month to be 9 months $2,000 a
month to be 4 and half $3,000 a month to
be 3 months so I think you should do it
in about 3 months kiddo oh man I wonder
why she never moved in like did she not
realize that when she signed other she's
currently going to college and who's
paying for that that's a qu that's the
question and is this kid still in this I
don't know what the attitude of the kid
cuz here's the thing I don't help
people who are continuing down the same
path I don't even coach them true that
okay and especi cuz it's not an act of
love it's an act of
helicoptering writing checks is an act
of helicoptering and you know
helicopters did you know helicopters
create snowflakes that's where they come
from that's that's good Dave but here's
what I'm wondering if here's what
happened what if she was like Mom Dad
I'm moving into an apartment and they're
like we don't want you to do that she's
18 what if she doesn't realize like hey
if you sign the lease like that's
legally binding and so she was like oh
my mom and dad don't want me move in
this apartment what what she does
realize is her mom and dad love her and
they're smarter than she is unless
you're a rebellious little twit and then
you go sign the thing anyway and you get
to pay the stinking $9,000 that because
you're a rebellious little twit and so
you get to do it I mean guess what you
know how I know this cuz I was her I was
the rebellious rebellious Twi I've done
everything stupid Under the Sun that can
be done so I recognize these attitudes
the question is for me and what we don't
have the information we don't have here
is the state her current state of yes
repentance repentance meaning I realized
I was wrong I'm sorry for that I goofed
up would you help me Absolutely I'll
help you yeah I'm not going to pay it
but I'll absolutely coach you and show
you and give you hope and I'll even talk
to the people with you and stand beside
you so they don't beat up a little
18-year-old kid anymore uh but if she's
to like well I you know I didn't know
what I know shut up you get to the whole
thing on your own then all right you
just get to wallow out there and you're
stupid if you're going to if you're
going to still be a twit right but
repentant is different you follow me I
yes I am I mean that that cuz she's
going to learn this lesson if she's
already learned the lesson and only has
to pay the bill that's the easy path if
she hasn't already learned the lesson
it's going to get painful before this is
done oh man and man let her experience
that pain at 18 otherwise she's 38 years
old and thinks that the world owes her a
living after she got her degree in
left-handed puppetry and she's a barista
listen Dave you and I saw this on two
different sides because you went
straight to rebellious little twit which
you you owned that and I'm looking at
this here here's what I'm looking at
when I was 18 here's how dumb I was well
you were sweet I did all right when I
was 18 I was dumb enough to think okay I
got student loans for school and you
know if there's leftover they give it
back to you called a refund right they
call it a refund it's not really a
refund you just borrowed too much money
but I took that money and I thought that
I was buying a car in
cash and I bought a car quote in cash
with my student loan that's how dumb I
was that's why I'm looking at this
18-year-old and I'm like did was anybody
looking at you that you that loved you
and said don't do that no what no
because when I told them I said I saved
up this money well no I'm sorry but if
they had realized what you were doing
told you not to do that they probably
would have stopped me yeah if they told
you not to do and you went and did it
anyway that's then you're set that's
where we're sitting here they said don't
do this right but she may not have known
that when she signed that lease she was
locked in Come On Dave think back 60
years no it's yeah I'm or 50 years thank
you but yeah it just doesn't matter a
lot of decades it doesn't matter no I
was already running businesses by then
so no I I knew what a you were smarter
than the average bear man I'm I'm
talking about these but the but hey mom
and dad looked at you and said said
don't do this it's a dumb idea that's
enough that's true that's enough that's
when you do full stop that's when you do
full stop and if you don't then you get
to eat $9,000 worth of stupid so um I'm
not saying she's currently rebellious
I'm saying at that moment she was I this
wasn't a sweet little interaction it was
against our wishes both he and his wife
looked at their little daughter and said
don't do this dumb don't do this and she
said I'm doing it anyway oh man that's
funny I don't I think she was like okay
I won't do it and didn't
know cause if she was a rebellious twit
she would have moved in realized after
two months she couldn't paid the rent
and then left but I'm like she never
moved in this is a mystery this is
Unsolved
Mysteries it's so fun you get to be the
daughter and I get to be the dad that's
the funny thing you're you're going to
take up for the poor little kid I know
my dad hammering my dad would have been
like you're on your own now you know
what now you know how Rachel was raised
okay I'm just saying now we know this is
how you create a Rachel Cruz right here
okay oh my gosh open phones at 8825 5225
yeah the trick is lovingly guide grown
children and when they're 18 they can
legally enter into a contract and if
they choose not to take your loving
guidance then you are under no
obligation to fix their mistakes as a
matter of fact you would be making
another mistake called enabling
helicoptering to go and fix their
mistakes regardless of the person's
attitude so now I will always come along
someone who admits that they made an
error and says I but now will you help
me I'm always got a lot of Mercy CU I've
been that guy too true that true that I
need Grace I need lots of Grace and and
so I don't mind extending Grace but I'm
not going to extend Grace that says oh
that was actually very smart when it
wasn't to the extent they don't learn
the lesson right because it's not it's
not helpful I get that they don't they
they don't you know if you don't if you
don't learn the lesson you get to do it
again if you flunk the test you get to
do it again is true that is true then
you just cycle stupid just ch dog
chasing its tail name stupid I mean you
just cycle it and I've done that too not
as much most of the time I do something
stupid it's only once and then I I move
on to another new stupid thing but wow
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
la
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality bestselling author of the
book money's not a math problem she's my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 Dylan is in Orlando hi Dylan
how are you hey Dave thanks so much for
taking my call sure what's up so I've
worked really hard and I've sacrificed a
lot to pay my way through school I'm
I've got one class left in my bachelor's
and I plan to go on to attain my
master's degree in Business cool I saved
up my money really well my girlfriend
and I live together and we've been
together for two years and she's in her
second of eight years to become a
veterinarian that's been her lifelong
dream it's going to put her in about a$2
200 to $250,000 hold of debt and the
average income for that degree in the
State of Florida is
$14,000 to me that's a scary amount of
debt and without waiting basically you
know 10 years to have kids buy a house
get married any of those things do you
have any thoughts on how to minimize
this debt or is it is it even a good
idea to get into and I can provide
background on each of our finances as
well if needed yeah when are you
planning to get married I'd like to get
married in probably two and a half to
three and a half years why so
long well we've had a few ups and downs
in our relationship and it's been going
it's been going pretty well but I also
want her to get some school under her
belt before we go and figure out some
you know other Financial things before
jumping into that with both of you and I
kind of want to have her grow with God a
little bit more my my relationship with
God's a little bit stronger and you know
her and I are growing in the faith
together but I kind of want her to get
to a good point with God and with the
idea of marriage before jumping into
marriage because I wanted to have a
chance to really succeed rather than
fail like more than 50% of marriage okay
so Dylan I hear you saying that you've
got a you've got a point you you want
her to be somebody different you want
her to grow with God not necessarily I
want her to have an opportunity to grow
with God rather than because she hasn't
had a chance to really meet God only
except for when she kind of met me
she she's a Christian person and you've
been with her two years correct okay I I
just I'm just being honest with you this
is I I don't know you I just met you two
seconds ago listening to you talk you
have a version of her that you want her
to be we don't know how long that's
going to take and this is a financial
thing this is a spiritual thing it also
sounds like there's some things with her
job that again you don't think it's a
good Roi for her school which don't get
me wrong I don't want her to go into
dead either but the things that you're
describing could
be red flags or could be deal breakers
you said you've had ups and downs listen
to maybe I'm wrong and this is people
can weigh in on this I I am of the mind
that when you're dating someone to marry
them it should be the best time ever
like it should be easy and and it
shouldn't be this ups and downs and I
need you to turn into this person that
listen that happens after you get
married after you get married is when
you're like I need you to be different
you know and so if you're facing that
now for me that's a that that could be
some that could give me some pause is
all I'm
saying right Fair a good point to think
about and and then other other than that
because then it's like okay like when
when couples who are dating are in
therapy I'm like listen give it up like
like you shouldn't be in therapy yet so
does that make sense I'm just a little
worried about some of the things you're
saying um don't get me wrong it's okay
to want someone to grow but you have a
three your trajectory of growth that you
think she needs before you can marry her
that's and that's a long time that's a
long time that's like you're waiting on
someone else to grow up and um or
something like that I mean she's 14 and
you're waiting until she's 17 I mean I I
don't know but I mean that's the way
that's kind of the that's a long time
anyway back to your orig back back to
your tact your Tactical question how can
she go to veterinarian school for less
than $200,000 well number one it depends
on where she goes to vet school because
vet schools are like all other schools
there is a vast spectrum of what they
charge um number two 114 is the average
but I know a lot of veterinarians that
make more than docks M uh it's the the
Pet World is a big expensive crazy world
now what people spend on their pets
including the ramsy is outrageous and so
um you know the uh there's a lot of
opportunity in that field because uh
America Americans budget for their pet
is it's crazy so uh yeah I I I think a v
a veterinarian is actually an excellent
uh field to go into I'm with you I would
try to limit or do away with the 200,000
in debt while I'm doing that I would do
that first with school choice I would do
that second with talking to some local
uh veterinarians that uh have big
practices that might uh chip in some
scholarship money or uh whatever to and
in return she agrees to work there her
first year out or something like that uh
there's even um the drug business in the
animal world is massive and if one of
those pharmaceutical providers has
scholarships for vets um in order for
the vet to look favorably on them later
um that wouldn't be unusual or unethical
uh and so I would be poking around on
all those kinds of things to try to
create money to move towards paying the
bill number one and then number two
lower the bill by where we go to school
um and so forth but um I want to play
with animals and I want to go $200,000
in debt to play with animals is not a
plan that's a childish view of a
actually a wonderful degree and I'm not
sure which of those she's taking I I was
not accusing her of that but I have met
people that uh since I was six I wanted
to be a vettiner and yeah but when you
were six you didn't understand what it
cost true and when you were six you
didn't understand it involved poop lots
of poop honestly you need understand you
didn't understand it involved Blood and
Guts and uh animals dying and so on and
they're not puppies they're old and
crusty when they come in it's uh you
know it's so you're not you're not six
anymore and so I'm I'm guessing she has
moved past that but um you know if we're
blowing up a six-year-old's dream that's
fine if we're drawing up blowing up a 24
year-old's dream and saying Define it
and approach your dream as an adult so
it doesn't become a nightmare true that
that I inant yeah and we can go that
direction and um so yeah I I would I
would do that um Dylan I'm going to jump
on one other thing and then uh because
you you walked into this brother I'm
sorry did you say y'all were living
together I'm all ears did you say you
were living together yeah did you say
you're living
together yes for financial reasons for
her she wouldn't have a basically a
place to live remember that God
part yeah yeah you remember that Bible
that goes with that God part I hear you
I felt like that was coming well I mean
I you you well I got another one coming
I don't like that he's like taking care
of her I don't I don't like that I feel
like she didn't have a place to she
doesn't have a place to live so I got to
give her a place to live she doesn't
know how to do this degree so I'm going
to show her how to I don't like this I'm
sorry Dylan I'm talking about you but I
don't like this relationship I don't I
want people who are equal and they see
eye to eye I feel like you're up here
and and you're viewing her down here and
you're big papa who's got to take care
of her I don't like that pretty young to
be a sugar daddy this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
big announcement today this is going to
be exciting you guys ready for fun this
is fun today we're announcing a brand
new event The Total Money Makeover
weekend it is happening May 10th and
11th here in Nashville at the Ramsey
Event Center there's millions of you out
there who have been listening for a
while and you're still sitting on the
sidelines no more sitting around time to
take action in just one weekend you're
going to get a crash course on
everything we teach about money you're
going to hear brand new content from the
Ramsey personalities on budgeting
beating debt investing and even more and
no matter what baby step you're on this
event will light a fire under your butt
to keep making progress on your money
goals there's going to be lots of live
q&as all throughout the weekend so bring
your questions and something that's
different about our events they're
actually fun and funny and with the
first 500 tickets sold you're going to
get a copy of The Total Money Makeover
for its 20th anniversary Edition and uh
we're going to sign that and I'm going
to sign that and send it to you don't
wait these are going to go fast early
bird tickets start today at $99 but for
a very limited time we're going to raise
these ticket prices very rapidly this is
going to be a sold out weekend at the
Ramsey Event Center with all the Ramsey
personalities Dr John deloney Rachel
Cruz George camel Ken Coleman Jade
washaw me we're all going to be speaking
it's going to be a great weekend you're
going to leave jacked up excited and
even tired from so much coming at you in
one weekend again early bird tickets
starting today May 11 and 10 10 and 11
here in Nashville on the Ramsey campus
early birth tickets only $99 you can get
them at ramseys solutions.com The Total
Money Makeover weekend we named it in
celebration of the 20th anniversary
edition of the book Total Money Makeover
coming out we got a new addition of the
book coming out um not a big deal there
just a little bit changes we caught a
few things up but um you know time to
time to Spruce her up ever so often and
so we're going to dress her up a little
bit put her back out and then we're
going to do this big event Total Money
Makeover weekend here in Nashville it's
going to be great I mean the lineup on
this and the all the different subject
matter it's going to be cover it's going
to be all new content yeah completely
new good stuff new content around old
ideas that's right there we go which is
what we've always done by the way all
right Tyler Is With Us in Atlanta
Georgia hey Tyler welcome to the Ramsey
show all right thank thank you guys so
much for the opportunity to be able to
speak with you here you too what's
up so I'm 34 years old um about to be
going through a divorce
unfortunately and how long you how long
you been married I've been married
almost seven years uh have have to have
two two little girls together man um so
uh my my question is as direct as I can
be with it is we've
been I I have bought into the baby steps
in the process and everything that we've
been working towards has has been in
line with that and now with this divorce
um it's kind of obviously throwing a big
wrench in into those plans a little bit
so what I'm trying to figure out is I I
purchased the home that we liveing
before we were married um so I know the
house will will stay with me um what I'm
trying to decide though is I have about
$71,000 worth of debt and I have roughly
between 200 to $250,000 worth of equity
in the house uh the plan was always to
pay off the debt sell the house and then
use that money to build a house outright
and become completely debt free so my
question I guess is um what do you make
what do you
make I currently make 84,000 a year but
uh within the next six months I expect
that to be between probably 100 to 120
based off of uh the incentives with the
new company that I'm at what is the
70,000 in
debt uh I have 18,000 in credit cards I
have 30,000 in a truck I have $10,000
worth of student loans and I was
previously uh had my own construction
company so I still have about $113,000
worth of debt related to that company
that I'm working on what is she
driving uh she is driving a vehicle that
her parents had given to her and it's
paid
for yes sir okay how old are your
girls uh five and one will be four
tomorrow um no I would sell my truck I
wouldn't sell my house MH
okay because I cut I cut your debt
almost in
half correct and you make $120,000 a
year coming up soon you can pay off
$40,000 in debt really fast as a single
guy with nobody telling you what to
do right so I'm um unfortunately that
the 30,000 is what I owe on the truck
but I'm I'm upside down in it I I took
out a higher interest rate loan on it
than I I I should have known better than
to do um so I'm not sure how to get out
how much upside down from
it uh probably about
$99,000 that's okay go borrow the $9,000
you got any money at
all I have very little saved up uh the
the the transition from when I was
self-employed to now working for
somebody else I I had about a 2 and a
half month period where I had very
little income and that that drained a
lot so what do you have
saved I have about $2,000 2,000 good
okay good so I yeah you're going to get
a loan for $99,000 if that's truly the
difference um you're guessing because
you haven't really looked it up because
you didn't say so I'm going to find out
from Kelly Blue Book what the private
sale value on this truck is and let's
get it sold it is the biggest item in
your situation and it moves the needle
the fastest the further and it's just a
stupid truck I would hold on to the
house I think the house is going up in
value the truck's going down in value um
and um you know part of what happens
when you're going when someone's going
through what you're going through um I
again we can even hear the sadness in
your voice there there's a there's a
grief and one thing that grief always
does to all of us um is it it Cloud we
get clouds in the brain for a little
while and so Jade and I have the benefit
of sitting here looking at your numbers
with cold logic and no emotion and
you're sitting there with two little
baby girls and a broken heart and a
failed construction company going into a
new job there's a lot of heart AE in
your life in the last 36
months correct and so when I said sell
your truck you almost
cried
[Laughter]
no it's no I'm not I promise you I have
no emotional attachment to the truck
it's uh it's it's it's it's it's a tough
situation it's one it's it's one I
didn't see myself in because I know I
know I
know I was not hey dude I'm not I'm not
making fun of you and I was not shaming
you either one I'm just observing that
any normal human being that's been
through the three or four things that
have hit you in the face in the last 3
years will
hurting you you would be if you're not
hurting you're a
psychopath okay right and so uh yeah and
in the middle of that to me it's very
you you want to just make all the debt
go away so the hurt goes away and
selling the house seems quick and easy
yeah uh you can do that if you want to
it's not a an immoral act or an
unethical act at all um I'm kind of
thinking those little girls' bedrooms
I'd like to keep them intact for a
little while that's what I'm thinking I
not at all costs but but if I if I can
choose a truck over that I'll I'll
choose keeping their bedrooms there yeah
I'm also looking back he said he had
13,000 from his construction business
I'm wondering if there's some things
that he can sell off to clear that a
little bit if there's something around
there maybe some negotiation with some
of those vendors at Pennies on the
dollar CU they don't think they're going
to get paid true that you've got options
yeah I I I think you can plow through
this debt pretty quickly if you got rid
of the truck um and that's that's where
I would go before I would go to the
house in your situation Rob but it's not
wrong to sell the house I just think
this other route might be better when
you look back 5 years later mhm this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
hey guys ramsy solution started small
and grew fast because of that rapid
growth there were times when our systems
slowed us down that's why we switch to
net Suite it works for us and it'll help
your business too whether you're
starting on a card table like I did or
you're well on your way to becoming a
multi-million doll Company netw Suite
can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay net Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than
37,000 companies use netw Suite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netw su's free kpi checklist designed to
give you consistently excellent
performance at netsuite.com Ramsey
that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey
personality number our bestselling
author uh money's not a math problem the
book just hit the bestseller list this
week so last week rather so uh she's my
co-host today open phones at
88255 225 Jade and I and all the Ramsey
personalities want to say thank you
for the number of you that share the
show subscribe to the show follow click
follow click
subscribe uh click the share button or
cut the link out and send it to somebody
or tell somebody where you listen on
talk
radio our ratings in every platform from
YouTube
to podcast to everything are way up we
had our billionth download on this show
and I it hit number one on all of Apple
podcast just the other day so thank you
for that we appreciate you helping us
you are our marketing program uh we
don't have $300 million to put in
marketing like a SOI excuse me um and um
so yeah you guys are it you have to help
us thank you we appreciate you uh
helping us uh share the show leave a
nice fstar review review the show share
the show subscribe all that kind of
stuff Melissa is in Paduka Kentucky hi
Melissa welcome to the Ramsey Show hello
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up well this is we started doing your
program several years ago kind of got
off track now we've got our baby steps
kind of all jacked up and yeah so your
baby's walking with a
limb pretty much it's like bowlegged or
something so anyways um me and my
husband we were just trying to decide we
I have a 401 okay that was started years
and years and years ago by employer um
I'm no longer with the employer haven't
haven't really done anything with it
it's with stocks it has grown some not a
whole lot um we haven't been putting in
it because we've been trying to work on
our baby steps so then
um we got our emergency fund we got like
10,000 our emergency fund and then we
have 15,000 in this
401K our question is is we don't have a
whole lot in like credit cards I hear
some people and I'm thinking holy crap
but we just have like $5,700 in credit
cards what's your household income 75
,000 are you guys uh you know we're
joking around about your baby and all
that stuff but are you guys really going
to do it this
time yes really yes yes I have to I have
to I have a daughter that's getting
ready to go to college with then let's
line this up and do it exactly like we
teach right exactly no no flinching is
the credit card dead it what else is
there um we have a car um how much you
on the car how much is the car um 35 to
$35,000 and your household income is
what 75,000 you told me that I'm sorry
and then you got and you have 15,000 and
how much in your emergency fund 10,000
okay go ahead I'm sorry I'm sorry and
then you've just got the 50 5700 on
credit cards that's it right and and our
house is 54,000 okay but that doesn't
come until later so why can't you reach
over with this emergency fund why can't
you reach over pay off those credit
cards and let's look at this
car and see about downgrading it and
aren't you done very quickly after you
do that pretty pretty much we just
didn't know um with that
401k um if we should since we're kind of
did the baby steps backwards if we
should pull we're to we're we're not
going to we're going to worry about
having done them backwards before we're
going to start going forward right now
okay right now if you started and you'd
never heard of us before and you called
us today we would tell you to take
everything out of your emergency fund
down to $1,000 and throw it at your
smallest debt how much in the emergency
fund again 10,000 okay so we paid off
the credit cards now have you cut up the
credit cards yet yes yes you have yeah
all of them all I only have one what
happened is is it cut up it is it is
what happened is um we had like three or
four just little ones and then we
transfer them over for um 0% APR for 24
months yeah but you never paid it off
didn't work no we've been no the 24
months don't end till December 31st so
write check write a check today and pay
off the credit cards now what about the
car and then and then you need to sell
your car okay car I've already been I've
been doubling up on the car the car is
too expens too expensive for you you
don't need a $35,000 car when you have a
$75,000 income mhm you shouldn't have
vehicles totaling more than half your
annual income and you do because you
have another
car right that's that's the only one we
have though you you have one car one one
car yes okay all right well you're right
at um half your annual income if you
want to keep it you can keep it but I
probably wouldn't I think it's too
expensive and I'd probably get about a
$10,000 car and let's pay that off as
quickly as possible and then your debt
free everything but the house no we
don't Cash Out 401ks besides that here's
a technicality you can't add to a 401k
from a place you used to work you can
only add to a 401k where you currently
work so that 401k you get with a smart
Vestor pro at Ramsey Solutions and you
roll it over to an IRA you clean out
your emergency fund you get your car
stuff straightened out I think you sell
the $35,000 car and you buy about a
$5,000 car for cash and um now now
you're debt free except your house you
build your emergency fund back up then 3
to 6 months of expenses and then you
start investing and you can be wealthy
then and I mean in 5 years you're going
to be in a way different position than
you are right now you can make this
stuff move pretty quick but you're going
to have to just start looking around
going I I want peace more than I want
this car I'd sell that car simply
because they need to feel something like
they've they've been down this road they
had a Bowlegged baby this is this is how
you start walking right is when you feel
it and it's you've got skin in the game
you know what I'm saying so I think
that's what they need yeah I I I would
and it's the thing is it's kind of it
stands out in the situation it it 100%
weird yeah you know it's not it's the
only big thing laying there and it's a
car and it's an out of- balance car so
it there's a lot of things that say sell
it so I I would if I were in your shoes
and it's not to say you don't get a
nicer car later but I wouldn't have that
car and I I would get rid of those
credit cards today I would not cash out
the 401K nope and we're going to use
that rest of that $10,000 to get rid of
this car and get you A5 or $10,000 car
and you pay cash for it as quick as you
can or pay it off very one or two months
that kind of thing and then you're 100%
debt free accept the house then you
build your emergency fund baby step
three 3 to 6 months of expenses then you
start investing in your 401k maybe step
four 15% of your income going in and if
you guys are serious about this uh I'm
going to have Austin pick up and put you
guys into Financial Peace University and
sign you up for every dollar uh the
every dollar premium and we're going to
give it to you free but if you're going
to do that you have to promise Austin
you're really going to do it cuz I don't
want to give it to you and you do
nothing with it something tells me there
are single income family did we ask that
something tells you there's room for
somebody to start working more yeah
could be could be it's possible no we
did not ask that but it's possible Rob's
in an Arbor Michigan hey Rob welcome to
the Ramsey
Show hey thank you thanks for having me
on the show sure um so I have a
situation I'd like to throw at you guys
and get your opinion um so I have a son
who's senior at Naval Academy um very
responsible he has no debt about 40,000
in the bank and one of the benefits they
offer the students is a low interest
loan yeah it's a horrible
benefit oh it gets these it gets these
kids in trouble all the time we run into
it the military all the time oh it's
awful well yeah I surely agree it could
be what he's done though is taking that
loan and he's dropped it into a six you
know 6% CD and what he's going to do is
when the CD matures is about the time
the payments are due put it in a high
yield money market and they draw off
that fund to pay it back over the term
of the loan and looking at the numbers
he'll probably put $78,000 in his pocket
once the loan is paid off get your
thoughts on that $7,000 does not make
you rich he has put a lot of risk at his
footsteps oh this is so scary now
there's so there's so much that can go
wrong here and so little that can go
right if he does it all perfectly he
doesn't make anything don't Mount
anything and so the Rob the way I gauge
stuff like this is I think okay when we
interviewed 10,000 millionaires how many
of them said I borrowed money at low
interest and put it in a high yield
savings and made the spread and that
made me a millionaire let me help you
out of 10,000 of them precisely zero
said that they would use a technique
like this they lived on less than they
make they save and invest they pay cash
for
things and your son had all of that
going until he did this and he tried to
get sophisticated all for just four
grand or five grand no I I would casat
that out and I'd pay it off today I
wouldn't walk around with this hanging
around my neck just for a couple Grand
it's just a the risk return on it is
horrid this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host cat is in Columbia South
Carolina hi cat Welcome to the Ramsey
Show Hi how are you better than I
deserve what's up in your
world so I just want to give you a
little bit of background um I'm a
graduate student right now and I have
usually been working three jobs at the
same time while getting my degree so
that I didn't have to take out loans for
grad school good for you what are you
studying some
loans
bology say it again
again wildlife biology oh wildlife
biology okay
cool okay um so I was able to follow
your methods and I was working on
getting my debt as low as possible
because I did have some um student loans
from
undergrad um but
unfortunately uh due to recent life I've
had to pull a lot more out of my savings
and I would like so now I have about
equal amounts of debt that I have the
savings um and I hopefully will graduate
in May but there's no guarantee that I
will have a job straight out of school
because the market so flooded in my area
so I was wondering if you had any advice
on which debt to focus on First and
formost um okay have you got all the
bills paid from now till May so there's
no debt associated with the
graduation no so I have about ,000 of
tuition left to pay for this semester
but I paid the rest of it for and you
have the money to pay the
thousand in savings yes I do okay we're
GNA because I don't want to add any debt
that's the first
goal yeah graduating with no new debt
and then how much debt is there
now do I have about $3,000 of student
loans which were originally paid off and
then Biden said he was going to refund
them so now I have to pay it off second
time
okay um and then I have $3,000 in car
loans about $300 in credit card debt
that I've Whitted down from about ,000
and $300 in medical debt okay well
you're you're a hardworking lady you've
been busting your butt I can tell by the
numbers and the way you're talking
through this and you're really on top of
and know your numbers so that tells me
you've been very intentional and
concentrating
congratulations uh so the the long and
the short is if you can graduate with no
more damage and then make enough doing
something until you land the big girl
graduate job uh that you can eat and pay
your bills I want you to tread water
till you land the big job and you should
land it within a month or two and when
you land the big job then we're going to
knock this out very very quickly does
that make
sense yes and you have you you're
telling me you got about 68,000 in
savings yes I do yeah I'm I'm not going
to start your Total Money Makeover till
you graduate and start your job because
it's only a couple months
away MH and I I'm just going to sit
there and let's make sure you graduate
with no more
debt that's the big thing I focus should
I focus on trying to pay down the
student loan debt before I graduate so
that it doesn't occur interest if you
have extra
money but I shouldn't spend my savings
on that is what you're saying that's
what I'm saying I think I I want your
savings there as a buffer to get you out
of school I mean you got two little ones
I'd write a check and get rid of those
two little ones today the $600 worth
three each
right yeah yeah and then you got 3,000
on the other two and um I'd sit on that
six and let's get on out of school and
pay the minimum payments and when you
come out of school as soon as you land
your job write a check be debt
free okay all right but I I I'm I'm
worried if we Whittle this down to
nothing then you're going to call me
back and say well I almost made it and
then I took out a student loan
yeah that's what I was worried about as
well is not having anything to pay the
bills when I graduate and may not have a
job at that point well you're going to
get a job doing something it may not be
in your field but I mean you're going to
be you're working now so you're you're
not afraid of work and you could start
applying before graduation for some of
the jobs in your area applying since
October and I haven't found anything
good okay so what is your dream job with
a with an graduate degree in wildlife
biology I would like to work for the
state um I know that that's not very
common but I changed my major when I was
a freshman because my mother passed away
and I figured that you know if life so
short you might as well you know invest
in something that you're going to enjoy
rather than something that's going to
make you rich so that's really my job is
to work for the state in wildlife
biology and really enjoy
it okay all right well if you don't get
on in South Carolina it may be North
Carolina Tennessee or Georgia right yeah
yeah I've been looking at other states
too good good so I mean you got you're
going to have to make some choices there
but uh because I want you to get the
utilization of this degree that you've
worked so hard for and paid so much for
and so let let's get that direction as
well but I I'm fine with just knocking
out the little ones yeah using cash
whatever she has left over to pay those
off I'm not mad at that Andrea is in
Fort Lauderdale hi Andrea how are you
hello I'm so excited to be here thank
you for taking my call sure what's up I
am calling because my husband and I we
purchased in 2021 a one bedroom one
bathroom condo for 140 which is now
worth about
230 awesome we have our first child on
the way yay and we're about $86,000 in
debt so we are eventually going to need
more space so we're thinking should we
sell and use the profit from the sale to
wipe out most of the debt or should we
wait because once the baby comes I'm
going to be at stay at home on for a
short season or should we wait until I
rejoin the workforce and then you know
once we're really needing the space make
that move what's your
incomes um currently combined we bring
in about 80 to
90 how much of that is
yours um about half I'm working parttime
right now because I had it rough in the
first trimester okay but I'm feeling
better now so starting in February I'm
going to go back to fulltime so we
should be at around a 100 combined all
right so a couple of options in my mind
stick out um you you want to be careful
in whatever analysis you do that you
don't analyze it through a child that is
18 Ines
long true that they don't take up they
don't take up much
space okay they take up they take up a
lot of emotional and spiritual space but
they don't take up much space they don't
even use half the stuff that you get
yeah until later on so you know you
could live in the condo for a little
while and just pay off the debt that's
an that is a valid option I know it's a
one-bedroom but again they don't take up
much space so uh lots of people have
done that in in human anity history so
uh then the other thing you could do is
you could sell the condo uh early in
your pregnancy because you don't want to
be moving late in a pregnancy that is
not fun right um you're gonna be really
unhappy if you're doing that and that
means everybody around you is going to
be unhappy so uh you can sell the condo
pay off all the debt and
rent for a little while until you can
build up some money for a down payment
so maybe rent for a year or more and you
could rent something that's a two
bedroom because right now our mortgage
with taxes HOA and everything is about
1,400 and Rens right now currently 21
and 22 apartments are going going for
about 1750 to 2000 listen if I'm you in
that Market Fort Lauderdale is crazy
Miami is crazy oh yeah I'm looking at
like what Dave said first off that would
be mine because your condo is only going
up in value and I would you know I'd sit
there till the baby's a year old and
then I would be and I'd knock as much of
the debt out as I can then I'd be
selling it Knocking out the rest of the
debt using the balance of the money for
your down payment on your next
deal okay that's what I would do I mean
i' I'd have a b in there and just deal
with it MH yeah that's just about what
we can fit we cannot fit a regular size
grp but a bassinet yeah we can yeah and
you know again they don't take up a lot
of room for a long long time uh you mean
there's there's lots of more luxurious
situations you can be in with a new baby
but that's not a bad situation in their
case though their condo could appreciate
faster than they are saving a down
payment oh that's true that that
Market's nuts that market is bananas you
just spoke there well you mov from there
but you spoke there at your old church
last weekend I did Church by the Glades
yeah yeah Big Dave's church so there we
go not this Dave the other one the other
one there we go you've worked for Dave a
lot I do that's what I do collect Daves
I love it this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships bestselling author Jade
washaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at Triple 8 825
5225 her new book money's not a math
problem a quick read 74 pages long
you'll be through it before you know it
hit the bestseller list last week so
she's an official bestselling author
just like that the phone number here
again 8825 5225 Carl's in Grand Rapids
Michigan hey Carl how are
you oh I'm doing good how are you Dave
and Jade better than we deserve what's
up um I have a question or looking for
advice um I recently engaged oh
congratulations when's the
wedding well I
June 21st or 14th of 2025 a year a year
and a half wow okay her little her
little brother is getting married right
before us so we took it easy on the
family but um
I'm trying to get a realistic idea of
like what to spend on a wedding it's
driving me insane I think it's
everything's astronomical right now but
she's also the love of my life and I
want her to have her day far done you
know um you're trying to fight against
your natural cheap skate
Tendencies correct correct I work get
out of the
whole H so what are what is what who's
paying for the wedding
um our parents combined luckily are
giving us $88,000 as a wedding gift like
just to pay for that and cool I am
responsible for the rest she's not she
does she have a say so as well or is she
contributing um I'm sure she could but I
feel like
as as the
guy provider quote unquote and know it's
oldfashioned and oldfashioned is her dad
pays for the wedding he
oldfashioned I think she I think she can
help yeah and he's not they're giving
you they're giving you $8,000 okay so
what do you make and wait let me real
quick say I just want to say it's both
your weddings it's not her wedding so
correct there you go yeah this is not
your gift to her this right this is you
guys getting married so what do you make
110 what does she
make 55 okay all right and how much debt
do you two have each of
you um I have 14,000 credit card
debt and I have 235 left on my mortgage
okay cool and how old are you
she 30 and how old is
she she is 28 okay cool does she have
any
debt she has 22 and a student loan okay
all right so 14 and 22 are one of our
targets the other Target is the wedding
budget and laying that out and all three
of those things should be gone during
this year and a
half okay and she should pay taken care
of the 22 you should be taking care of
the 14 and then the two of you add to
the eight to get to the wedding budget
do we have any has anyone discussed any
numbers as to what you all think you
would spend on the
wedding well yes I said I
said I would like to be under 20 because
I think that's astronomical I think
that's
insane you're you're I don't mind your
budget but it's not astronomical or
insane the average wedding in America
last year was
29,000 that was the average so astronom
and insane would be double that I I
think you guys need to get tactical cuz
it sounds like you're kind of pulling
these numbers out you both need to be on
an every dollar budget and let's get
tactical and find out okay like Dave
said um if you're paying off your debt
which was the 14,000 what would you
realistically have left at the end of
every month after you've paid that debt
off to set aside for the wedding and
then do the same thing for her so that
you guys can actually arrive at a number
because at the end of the day you can
only the wedding can only cost what you
can afford is she living at
home no she is living in our my house
soon to be our house okay all right um
well I would like for her to use her 55
and clear her debt I would like you to
use your great income to clear your debt
and add to the wedding budget and if 20
is the budget then you need 12 more
right correct but it's that's not an
astronomical number it's not a bad
number it's a nice wedding mhm um and I
I know people they get married for half
of that and I know people that spent 5x
that so uh either but you know there's
not a moral construct here uh but I
think if you set the wedding budget at
20 you put in the 12 which is kind of
was your intent anyway in this call and
you make you know double what she makes
and you've got half the debt she's got
so that's okay all of those things
indicate you could fund that 12 you you
knock your 14 out fund the 12 she knocks
out her 202
right correct I'm in for for that and
then uh then we do a $220,000 wedding
okay if $20,000 is the wedding budget
the two of you need to already start
breaking that down because that is a
vague number to uh Jade's Point M yeah
like if you haven't if you haven't
called some places and you haven't sat
down and talked to her and been like hey
what what are your thoughts to really
see um yeah in other words this is a
project yes and you manage it like you
were building a house you have a line
item budget i' had three big weddings at
the Ramsay uh years ago and uh the best
thing we ever did was we put a number
and then we backed into a budget and
said okay on a $20,000 wedding that
means the dress budget is X MH whether
that be $1,200 or 800 but it's somewhere
around there that means the reception
which is the most expensive thing
typically is why and that means the
photographer is z and each of these
numbers you you know and uh the church
or the venue is going to be you know a
or b or whatever $220,000 you're going
to have to be really care clear on what
the what your priorities are is it the
venue is it the food is it the D like
you have to you're going to pick one or
two top priorities and everything else
is going to fall in line I've seen
people spend 20 grand on the flowers
that's right so you're going to have to
say the flower budget is whatever it is
and you got to set that out and and then
you when you're sitting down with a
caterer
and they have the little tasting thing
before you decide what the is going to
be served at the reception you go uh
like Father of the Bride we're having
the cheaper chicken I know that's right
when you start seeing how much it costs
per head you go you'll lose your mind
you'll lose your mind yeah and
tactically just think about it like this
uh one last little tactical thought
sometimes you think about oh okay I'm
going to spend $20,000 on a budget and
once I have $20,000 I'm just forking it
over no you got to be thinking about
what chunks of money you need to have
ahead of time to put deposits and things
like that so really sit down and plan
this out because you don't want to have
any excuse to go into debt even if it's
temporary if you do not have this line
item out 100% of the time you'll go over
budget that's right every time because
you'll be in the Heat of the Moment you
go that's the dress your Heat of the
Moment I want to upgrade and do this
level of V videography uh the Heat of
the Moment I love this particular little
appetizer and all of the sudden you're
spending a 100 M they go there in a
heartbeat man this is the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade ww Ramsey personality is my co-host
today she has one of the three new books
we just put out all of which have hit
the best seller list or at least we
think georgees has we'll know next week
uh Rachel's new book I'm glad for what I
have a children's book about contentment
our first ever Illustrated Kids book by
Rachel uh perfect to help parents spark
a great conversation with their kids on
contentment uh Breaking Free from broke
with George camel we launched that book
this week we'll know bestseller list and
so forth next week on it it is selling
very
well bless excuse me thank you thank you
wow and uh great data in that book and
then Jade's book uh money's not a math
problem it's a 74 page quick read and uh
hit the best seller list last week so
all three of these new books are
available along with many other
wonderful things at ramseys
solutions.com check out the store we'll
help you out it's what we do all right
Heather's in Nashville hi Heather
welcome to the Ramsey
Show hey guys thank you for taking my
call um the question is should we stop
saving for baby step 3D in order to fund
for uh my husband to make a career
change to be a pilot
interesting
so not buy a house instead be a pilot
for now for now yeah how much is it
going to cost for him to be a
pilot it's what we've seen what we've
looked at it's been about 80 to
110 cool how long would that take to
save up that money and how what what are
the chunks that you need it in the
reason we're considering stopping is so
we can try to get him through in about a
year a year and a half
okay neither answer is wrong it really
is just you guys looking at this and
deciding what your priority is what does
he make
Now 60 65 okay that's about what he'll
be making as a starting commercial pilot
too that's after he's gotten enough
hours to fly a jet
commercially which I don't know if
you're going to get that many hours for
adk do
you
um for 80,000 well yeah we we thought so
between 80 to 110,000 yeah okay that's a
lot of hours to get commercial jet
certified um I don't know I mean uh if
you get there that's fine but you're
going to spend that for him to make
about what he's making
now starting now eventually he can fly
the big boys and he can make double or
triple that but but you don't start in
those sure right of course what what's
he do
now he's a he's an electrician do you
guys have kids no no kids and what we
were thinking was we were trying to take
advantage of the cheap rent we have
right now uhuh while while um pushing
him through
school I mean I can I have limited
knowledge only what you told me but I'm
thinking to myself okay there's not a
big press it's not like I'm busting at
the seams with my my home and I need to
buy a house so there's part of me that's
like okay maybe this is a great time to
pursue this what do you
make I make 70 85 okay and so you got
130 together he stays in his job while
he's in Pilot School correct yeah and uh
you guys have how much saved towards the
80 or 100 already we have nothing saved
we're flowing it as we uh we put him
through school okay cash flow okay so
you're uh you've already started then
he's been trying it yeah he's only done
like three or four
flots okay this is not yeah yeah it's
not a te it's not a technical school
it's a just him picking up hours with h
flight instructors yeah okay so before
you make the rest of this decision I
think you need more detail than you
have um I mean I know a tiny bit about
this enough to know that you guys have
not run this all the way down and so
what I want you to do I want you to
detail out exactly where he's going to
go to school exactly how many hours he's
got and exactly how many jobs are out
there and what they're paying uh I
talked to a commercial pilot yesterday
that was on the millionaire theme hour
and he was making
300 uh and I asked him what a junior
level starting pilot was making right
now cuz you typically go in flying The
Regionals like an American Eagle or
something like that and he said they're
starting at
65 that's guy yesterday so that
information I know is correct and uh the
only other thing I know is it takes a
lot of hours to be certified not only
fly jet versus prop but also to fly jet
commercially and have passengers right
whose lives are dependent upon you so I
want you guys to really get that dialed
in
exactly right my understanding is that
our understanding is it takes about
1,500 hours to get to that first job
yeah his instructor was I don't know how
you get 1500 hours in one year listen if
you can year year year and a half I
don't know how you do that I I think you
really got to sit down with a school
that says here's how we're going to map
that out it's going to be this many
hours this month this many hours that
month and here's the cost exactly and uh
then the second piece is I'm going to
get on the other side of that and I'm
going to line the job up to where I know
what I'm going into and um uh and so cuz
most of the pilots I talk to the people
wanting to do what your husband's
wanting to do um are addicted to Flying
it's it's an addiction and they will do
almost anything to do it including lie
to themselves about what it costs and
how long it takes and what they're going
to make so uh like I'll give you an
example I'll bet your husband doesn't
believe he's only going to make 65 yeah
he probably thinks he's going to make
more he probably thinks he's going to
make 130 and he's not okay that's just I
just talked to the guy yesterday Heather
so I'm I'm making this up he's a
commercial pilot been a commercial pilot
in the big jets for uh uh for 20 years
and he's a millionaire now but he said
it that that isn't where it starts and
everybody talks about that's you know
you just start there and you don't start
there you might start there or close to
there if you come out of the Air Force
but uh but going through flight school
the way your husband is no you're not
going to I'm not riding on a plane with
somebody who's only been flying one one
and a half years yeah you have no don't
tell me that da oh gosh that's scary you
you got $1,500 she's right about that
you've already done that but uh yeah I
need my pilot to have been in the Air
Force and then he turned around you got
on more of these regionals and notice
that these kids look like they're
younger than your socks listen I try not
to do it they're there I'll tell you I
have I need I need my pilot to have some
gray
hair good luck with that glasses looks
like Opie Taylor up there his name is
Mike like I need somebody who's been in
it for a while not a year don't tell me
that it's it's okay they're they're
competent they're fine they're just
young and uh and they got quick reaction
skills cuz they're young so that's good
you want them up front listen the person
I don't know if I don't know if you want
the codger up there the person driving
the plane and the person delivering the
baby needs to have gray hair it's all
I'm telling you
Dave those are two areas where you
want you don't want doie Hower as your
OB no I don't want anybody who's younger
than
me oh my gosh I love I love it all right
Heather more detail and then yes go your
plan run your plan out but base your
plan on facts not wishes of someone who
just loves to fly okay because there's
something that uh is about flying about
you know uh as a friend of mine who's a
pilot says when you're Landing it's
actually a controlled crash gosh and so
um he said there's something about that
is just thrilling and fun and addictive
and people tend to ignore the economic
realities of becoming a pilot and so you
want to really get into that and
actually know exactly talk to major
airlines and say are you hiring and
what's the come what what's the rate
coming in learn what that is what what
am I going to be entering at and then
lay the flight school out to get the
$1,500 if that's actually what it is for
the certification I'm not positive you
are but I'm not and so get all that laid
out exactly and then yall go do it I
think you're we're endorsing the plan we
just want we want you to plan it in more
detail so it is an actual plan and not
just a dream yeah and I think you're
close you you got some of the stuff
gathered but also think you haven't dug
it all the way out yet MH and then if
you're willing to wait on your house for
your husband to become a pilot then that
makes you a championship wife way to go
that's cool this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
oh
[Music]
James is with us in Miami hi James
welcome to the Ramsey show thank you
thanks for having how are you better
than I deserve what's
up hey I've been following you guys for
for a year appreciate everything you do
um I uh when I found you feel Kindred to
to how you guys uh think about about
money and debt um I'm in a really good
spot I'm 37 um I have a netw worth
probably about 1.3 uh two
properties um each of those properties
does have a mortgage one's at 200 one's
at uh 250 my primary house the other one
is rented at a pretty good profit
um I my life circumstances have changed
a bit I had twins um you know and
thinking about uh yeah I've had a couple
couple of blessings come into my life um
changes things life obviously had to
stop working um and but right now I'm at
a Crossroads where I'm debating what to
do uh I've seen all the money we've
printed and inflation and uh definitely
a little bit I I have money invested in
the stock market um I'm pretty cash
heavy at the moment and de what to do
with that cash do I um I have 3.75 rates
on both my properties um and 25 on one
and 20 years left on the other no no
other debts no credit card got rid of
all my paid off all my student loans
paid off all my cars um pay cash for
pretty much everything now I put in
solar paid cash for that um you know
what's the what's the balance on the
mortgages uh 200 on the rental property
that's cash flowing about 1,200 a month
um and the uh that's after paying paying
the mortgage and all the all that and
then uh 250,000 on the house that I live
in so how much cash you're sitting
on uh cash so um outside my my like IRAs
IAS are at about 450 my actual cash on
hand is uh slush cash is about 80 with
another 50 kind of just invested in the
market so I'm debating do I you know I'm
I'm thinking there might be a dip do I
do I leave it there I also have 225,000
um Florida has a prepaid thing for for
student for future student loans for
your kids so um I'm On A Five-Year Plan
with those I could pay them off if I
want um you know I can pay off my
property I can start to put I I cash
flow probably around uh 15 uh a month
what do you make a year what's your
personal income about 350 okay James
you've done extremely well
congratulations congratulations I mean
what a beautiful job you've done um you
know the the only the only point that
our discussion would have with you is
not to help you uh not to help you
become a millionaire you already did
that okay and not to help you do that it
might be just that you know I'm sitting
here with the buildings I'm sitting in
for instance are um about 600 million in
value roughly okay and uh they're paid
for and so and that's just a portion of
I mean that's the larger portion of our
real estate portfolio but I've got a
bunch of other real estate I love real
estate and of course we ey on ramsy
Solutions as well which has a value and
so on so uh I'm I'm a few years ahead of
you is all I'm saying I'm not better I'm
just ahead of you I'm older uh D come
near twice your age and so uh you've
just done extremely well so if I were if
I were talking to you um and I don't
really don't know exactly what you're
asking I I would probably just give you
a couple things I would do and that
would just be fine-tuning
a an a a an engine that's already
running really well okay uh this is not
the the car is not about to blow up
you're not about to bankrupt you're not
done anything stupid you know you're
doing a whole lot of smart things so I
have found and and you listen to us for
10 minutes you know this that the less
debt I have the more peace I have and
the better my cash flows are and the
lower my risk is thus the peace is up
less anxiety so you know for instance
this building uh we have a pandemic hit
I've got a 00 team members that are on
payroll I want to make that payroll I
don't have to pay myself the rent uh
because there's no you know there's no
mortgage on the stupid building so I
don't have any stress that's an extreme
situation but with more zeros on it but
still give it still outlines the idea
that first thing I would do if I were in
your shoes is I'd start working towards
getting my home paid off without cashing
out any return to do it then the next
thing I do is I pay that rental off and
okay so pay the the house for first than
the rental yes yes I want my personal
residence where I sleep to have zero
mortgage there is more than just math
and investing going on here there's a
spiritual element to this a
psychological and a relational element
to this your wife will feel different
you will feel different when you lay
your head on the pillow you don't think
you will but when it is paid for you
will okay so my one my one counter to
that and this is I guess the next point
of of information is I'm debating so my
I bought my house back in 2012 so I have
it at a great interest R and a great
value um the the other thing is if I
ever wanted to now that I have twins
which I have plenty of room I have
enough room 21100 square feet um four
bedroom so there's enough room but when
family comes to visit my parents are
getting older her parents are getting
older people are coming to stay for
longer than we maybe want paid off
houseold quick as a mortgaged
house I'm not thinking about paying it
off I'm thinking about expanding it okay
pay off with expand it with cash you
make $350,000 a year
mhm okay so what's happened is is you
hit a plateau and you
quit uh pinching every little nickel and
and you relaxed a little bit and it's
gotten a little
sloppy okay it's what I'm seeing I might
be wrong but if I were you I'd pay off
your house goal I think you've been
working so so hard putting your head
down and plowing forward to hit whatever
the goal was
and you've gotten there and now you just
need another very clear goal to keep you
motivated and the only other thing I
would do is I wouldn't do Florida
Prepaid College yeah that's garbage uh I
would just do I would just do good
mutual funds in a 529 uh a lot more
flexibility a lot more options to do for
college and you can make a much better
rate of return than Prepaid College
anytime you prepay something James your
rate of return is the inflation rate of
the item tuition inflation rates have
been about 8% for the past two decades
and so you're making about 8% on your
money you could make you could do better
than that in a good mutual fund and and
you'd have more flexibility so I would
move the prepaid stuff into a 529 again
a minor tuneup paying off your house
minor tuneup and paying off the mortgage
on the rental minor tuneup somewhere in
there cash flowing the expansion if you
want to expand or change that house that
you're living in any of that's okay but
uh you keep going back to the mortgage
interest rate I don't give a crap what
your mortgage interest rate is mine's
zero you can't beat my
and you can't beat the cash flow I've
got on our properties they flow they
cash flow like a bandit and I don't I
don't think about my home at all it
doesn't come up in my financial brain it
doesn't even it doesn't it's just it's
just a really calm safe place to go
sleep yeah you know and it just changes
everything and I've been because I've
been debt free on the house for so long
that it just my my spirit doesn't even
connect to that I can't I can't imagine
how I would you know how how I would
sleep if I had a mortgage yeah I could
see that I could see now because I've
been doing it for so long so that that's
all we would do James but again you're
97% on board with what we would do those
are just a few tuneup things and way to
go hero I mean you killed it 37y old
millionaire man excellent well done well
done and and did it from nothing
starting from nothing didn't inherit it
he's not a not a um not a rock star not
an actor not not not an NFL star not to
our knowledge anyway and if he plans on
buying more real estate obviously cash
for that yeah pay cash after you get the
other stuff paid off and you could build
a really large portfolio 10 15 years
from now of real estate if you fooled
around with this and have it all paid
for in the process and pay cash for it
as you go MH it wouldn't you know once
you clear these two properties so but
that's what we would do you do whatever
you want uh you're you're obviously not
a dumb guy so well done well done hero
proud of you that's very cool those guys
are everywhere mhm mhm people that have
done smart stuff with money in a in a
culture where we most people spend spend
like they're in Congress oh yeah that's
normal go into debt by the way don't
miss $350,000
income $1.7 million net worth yeah 37
years old 2200 ft
house yeah don't miss that he's living
below his means that that he not 8300
mhm
2200 living on Wes he makes this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
our scripture of the Day Psalms 1458 the
Lord is gracious and compassionate slow
to anger and rich in love Thomas
Jefferson said if angry count to 10
before you speak if very angry count to
100 okay uh Tyler is in Michigan hey
Tyler welcome to the Ramsey Show hi
thanks for having me sure what's up so
my wife and I we came to the realization
and knowledge that hey we don't want to
be in debt anymore um and we have an
obstacle that's kind of in our way
hindering um our get out of the debt
plan so every three
months go we have um to save up for a
custody exchange where we have to travel
two space away U and that's about $400
to $500 so how do we navigate that in
saving up our emergency fund as well as
paying off our
debt I think it's just something that
you're planning for monthly throughout
your budget yeah if you had if you had a
$500 electric bill it' be the same thing
right yeah okay so how would you do that
well you're going to manage your budget
meaning we're going to cut expenses all
over the place and we're going to do
anything we can to get our income up
extra jobs and overtime and or new
careers so what's your household income
uh last year we made um
$68,000 okay all right and how much debt
do you guys have uh together between
cars credit cards and personal loans
we're at
42,000 and how much of that
car uh 30,000 m one car uh two cars okay
I mean one car that's
30,000 uh no sorry U between the two
sorry that's that's both of them 25,000
between two cars so it's comb it's
30,000 and is the breakdown of that is
what so one car is 129 and the other one
is uh 11 okay about half and half then
okay all right yeah if I'm you I'm just
plugging these numbers I'm guessing this
is you driving to another state so this
is gas food are you staying overnight
one night what is
it my wife and I we Turn and Burn uh we
try to cut expenses as much as possible
like we'll pack sandwiches and stuff but
yeah mostly food will stay the relative
house if we need to that kind of stuff
mostly gas and car Main and uh whose
children are these yours or your wife my
wife your wife's children okay and how
old are
they uh oldest is 10 youngest is three
okay all right well
um so here's the only hope I can give
you on this that that where here's the
light at the end of the tunnel if you'll
continue
to work extra tighten your budget clear
these debts
if you had a larger income and no debt
this would be much less of an
issue obviously no kidding right but um
but you know the point is is that if
you'll work for a couple years here and
get these debts cleaned up and in the
process of that review your careers and
say where are we going with our careers
and you get your income up which most
people do throughout their life that's a
fairly standard living process right but
uh let's pretend two years from now
you've got a household income of 880 and
no payments but a house
payment all of the sudden this is a
different discussion
right and so it's really not what's
killing you it's all the other stuff
that's killing you is my point it it is
it's highlighted because it's an
emotional thing that you're doing and
it's draining to drive two states over
yeah yeah we have a plan to use our um
income tax this year to go right towards
crushing a lot of the interest debts and
the smaller debts great have you changed
your have you changed your withholding
so you don't get a refund
anymore uh have not done that you're
expected to get a refund yeah I would
change that because having that money in
your monthly cash flow every month is
going to be of way more value to you
yeah especially with this situation
going a refund just means too much is
coming out of your check in other words
that's not something we knew about so
yeah so what's your refund
typically um right now it's close to
eight okay cool yeah so we're talking
about 700 bucks a month yeah that's
pretty substantial no it's not yeah yeah
700 700 yeah it is it's a lot of money
yeah that that would clean up a lot of
stuff right there so yeah let's look at
changing your withholding if that's been
your refund every year bring home that
700 and as Jade said you'll still get
the eight from from 23 when you file
your taxes in 24 but go ahead in 24 and
set it up where you don't get a refund
next year instead you get the money now
cuz all it is is an interest free loan
to Washington DC and then they give it
back to you and act like they did you a
favor yeah so very cool I think you're
going to I think you're going to see
some progress here hang on I'm going to
have Austin send you a copy of the book
The Total Money Makeover and a copy of
Jade's new book money's not a math
problem you guys read through both of
those and see if it hadn't help you get
some traction on these things Christine
is in El Paso Texas hi Christine how are
you hi good how are you better than I
deserve what's up thank you for taking
my call I'm calling because I'm 53 so
I'm late to your method um the question
is after I finish um and get to the
investment stage um at my at the point
in my age can I in should I be investing
more than 15% into Investments do you
have a house payment still I do yes yeah
no you should put 15% because we need to
get you at retirement with an S EG and a
paid
house okay so first I will pay off the
house and pour all the extra money into
that and baby step bab okay your dead
free accept the house you have an
emergency fund of 3 to 6 months of
expenses then okay we do baby steps four
five and six at the same time four is
15% of your income going into retirement
five is kids college if that even
applies in this situation six is we
throw extra money at the house and try
to get the house paid off typically
people will pay off their homes in some
where around 7 to 10 years from the time
they
start okay which would put you at a paid
for house at
retirement Goa what's your household
what's your
income my income is 115 great are you
single yes I am cool so if you'll drop
into an investment calculator sit down
with an investment C with a smart Vestor
Pro you're going to find $20,000 a mon a
year going into uh good mutual funds for
15 years is going to give you a really
nice Nest
Egg okay I am starting very late so that
was my huge concern is that I will never
I want you to do it because you are
starting late but if you do it if you
put 15% of 115,000 20,000 bucks a year
into good growth stock mutual funds and
your 401k and Roth IRAs and you do that
for 15 years you're going to have
substantial money and you're probably
going to be doing think about that what
Dave said you're probably going to get
to that sooner like for instance if you
pay off your house in the next s years
it won't just be 15% it'll be more
because after you pay the house off
you'll be adding more yeah you can load
more and more and more in then yeah um
so but I mean 10 year in 10 years you're
67 so we want the house paid for
absolutely because what we find
Christine is a paid for home and a nest
egg are the two essential things to
stabilizing your golden years if you
retire with a paid for home and no money
that's not stable if you with a paid
with a pile of money and not and a big
old mortgage that's not stable so what
we want is we want the that that largest
line item in your budget which is
housing we want that to drop way down
and be extremely stable and peace around
the subject of it being your your you
know you know your house as yours and uh
then we just put as much as we can put
in those old retirement accounts to see
where we can get there I mean when you
have zero payments suddenly what you
need to live on monthly is a lot lower
yeah that's true too that's true
but I mean if you work like to 70 in
your case Christine um I'm going to I'm
trying to do this in my head
but you're going to have about
$600,000 I like it plus a paid for house
if you pay off your house by in 10 years
and um and you work till 73 more years
you're going to have $600,000 in Nest
Egg if you'll sit down with a good smart
Vestor Pro put them into good mutual
funds you know pick good fun and always
do it don't ever stop and then every
extra dollar let's let's figure out what
the house balance is and what do we got
to do to get it paid off yeah and the
faster we get it paid off then you can
do what Jade said and that's jump in
there and throw extra above the 15% in
that nest egg and then we can start
talking about cranking back uh
the cranking back the retirement date uh
from 70 to 68 to whatever at that point
so you'll be okay Christine you got this
that puts us hour the the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus
a